[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
happy birthday getting too old for this
guys but it is my birthday and this year
I'm gonna be turning the big three oh
hello yes it is my 30th birthday and to
kick things off I'm getting making some
birthday cake protein waffles
they are super delicious it's actually
really well balanced and healthy so
you're gonna wish it was your birthday
everyday so guys let's get to this to
food processor I add my gluten-free oats
and process that until it turns into a
flour set it aside then I add in my
cottage cheese and I period that until
it reaches a creamy light consistency
next I added some mashed ripe banana
vanilla extract cinnamon salt and my oat
flour and I carry that together until
it's nice and smooth next I add in all
my eggs and then process that until it
reaches a nice creamy and batter
preheat my waffle iron and add in a
healthy helping of the batter along with
some rainbow sprinkles and some rainbow
candies because hey it is my birthday
then I cook it until it's golden-brown
and I stack them high with some Greek
yogurt sliced bananas
strawberries a drizzle of almond butter
lots more rainbow sprinkles and my maple
syrup enjoy
[Music]
so guys I may not be drinking this year
but honestly these protein birthday cake
waffles are a great way to get the party
started so I hope you enjoyed this
recipe if you did be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below with
what you guys like to eat on your
birthday subscribe to the channel and
I'll see you next time on Abby's kitchen
bye do you